hello everyone yesterday's game between
Argentina and Croatia was really insane
and the result in the end was even even
more insane 3 2 0 against such a strong
team is a really unbelievable and after
that first goal that was that was really
just a blunder then you know they had to
change their strategy and you know to
create more chances you have to allow
your opponent to create even more
chances and you know as in chess then
everything went downhill for them so
that's how I saw it but you know I'm no
expert here now this game it comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber who used
his vast knowledge to do some extensive
research his name is Jacob Roth and he
found a game hell were Croatian player
faces and Argentinian player over the
chess board so in honor I guess to
celebrate Croatia's greater victory from
yesterday now ok let me get all night or
fees originally from Poland but you know
after after the Ardwick of the world war
he moved to Argentina and then he stayed
stayed there and he played for Argentina
so it's the closest you know he could
find and very very grateful for for the
extensive research now a lot of you may
not have heard of him but Brussels
robber is an international master from
Croatia and he is pretty famous here but
even I haven't seen this game until now
so the game is from the Gothenburg into
inter zonal tournament in 1955 it's a
tournament that it was a twenty one
player round-robin and nine players who
qualified from this tournament will go
play the 1956 candidates tournament in
Amsterdam so both of these tournaments
are very nice we're gonna talk about
them some more after the game and you
know it's also maybe not a bad idea for
a series now Brazil of rubber like we
said he played in the Chess Olympiad
three times for Yugoslavia in 1950 1952
and 1954 and in 1951 he was the the
champion of Yugoslavia and it's very
interesting he designed the opening
classification system that was used in
the chess informant
so quite a guy and
you know like I said although pretty
famous in Croatia I've never actually
seen this game it's it's a game like we
said played in the intro song tournament
against night off and although you know
there are a lot of things that are
enjoyable in chess but you know when
neither goes for the night or variation
that's that's always very enjoyable so
let's check it out
we have efore by Robert c5 Knight to f3
d6 let me just fix that so d6 d4 seek
after Sundy for Knight captures Knight
to f6 Knight to c3 and of course all of
you know what
neither of place here goes for a 6 the
knight of variation of the Sicilian
brush up to g5 we have E 6 and now f4
it's very interesting in the whole
history about this f4 idea Queen to f3
was also was also a move that was used a
lot of times but after a very famous
game between Bronstein and either then
f4 came into practice you're also
welcome to check out the famous game
between Borenstein another night or I
will put a link to it in the description
below
it's also very enjoyable so f4 we have
Queen to c7 this is all standard theory
of the night of Queen to f3 knight c6 we
have queenside castle Bishop to d7 and
Knight back to b3 avoiding the exchange
in the center Bishop to e7 and now
Bishop to h4 this Bishop is no longer
really useful on g5 he wants to play g4
and put this Bishop on g3 wherever it
can x-ray the Queen on c7 and also when
the bishop is still on g5 if you play it
something like g4 immediately then black
can go into a very unpleasant series of
exchanges with h6 and the g5 and after
you capture in 95 then you have to go
move the Queen Queen g3 and then after H
captures Bishop captures you will have
this nice captures on g4 but rope
capture screen captures and black pretty
much solved all of his problems so it's
not the only variation but you know you
don't you don't want to allow this with
with with the tempo so rush up to h4 we
have castles and the now comes g4 rook F
the c8 preparing a nice battery here
to always either at sea to pond and
maybe threaten some checkmate ideas in
the future
Bishop to g3 and now comes b5 you have
to kick away that night from c3 we have
E 5 here and this is the critical moment
can can black capture in the center or
must black move back so as you want to
assist the hardest move to find is with
the knight back so let's let's check
what happens if D captures on e5
displayed this is actually possible but
to actually play this you have to either
know it by heart or you have to really
like spend an hour over the boards to
find it because after D captures F
captures on e5 you have to play it in
Knight captures on e5 and now after
Queen to e2 pinning this night you have
to figure out how to do it of course you
can't do play Bishop d6 wroclaw simply
capture it and then you will lose two
pieces for a rook the idea you have to
find these Knight captures here so now
the night will be protecting the the
other night on e5 and you have to see
that after h3 Bishop to a3 is actually
the move you have to find now any move
but nice the b1 losses for white so of
course if you capture then Queen will
capture here and well the only thing you
can do is nice to be one simply get that
night out and wait and now attack the
bishop here and here you have to find
Bishop to e7 once again and now you have
to once again find that this is
impossible because worship to g5 and
what is getting checkmated there is
nothing you can do whatever you put in
front of the bishop the bishop will
simply capture it unless you block what
the rock then Queen captures and C 2
will be checkmate instantly so e 5 a
very prepared idea or a big inspiration
over the board by brass lava robber and
night off doesn't go for it he plays
nice to e8
which is also also very strong we have
Queen - E - now now comes before kicking
away that night and now he kept force
and e6 first and in-between move Bishop
captures and now nice the e4 wooden an
attack on the bishop on d6
Bishop captures an f4 would check and
now kink the b1 Bishop captures H
captures and now nice to d5 so neither
pretty much sold all of his problems he
did give Robert
open age file but it's not gonna be all
that easy to use it
rubber immediately tries to take
advantage of it by Queen to h2 simply
threatening capture on h7 we have H 6
and now g 5 he wants to break open the
position but neither of proceeds
correctly rush up to c6 attacking
tonight we have Bishop to d3 defending
now comes Knight captures pawn captures
the bishop captures pawn captures and
now Queen to e5 a very nice idea by
night or foe once again G captures on h6
and now Queen captures on e4 with check
King to a-1 and now comes rock to sea to
once again neither of night of plays the
best move here Queen to h5 was played
with ideas of pushing h7 and then maybe
capturing on f7 Knight to f6 attacking
the Queen and here raslak Robert does
push h7 and this is the critical moment
in the game what do you play here the
strongest continuation is King to h8
after King to h8 you have to allow Queen
captures this and then black simply
proceeds white wet can't really do
anything to break through here black
would be perfectly fine here even even
better another thing after h7 you could
go for Knight captures an H and this is
also possible but then you run into rook
to d4 attacking the Queen and after
Queen moves rope here you can't move the
knife from h7 because you're getting
checkmated and even if you exchange
Queens you're still gonna lose the night
on h7 because rope was simply captured
you can't move it because rakesh 8 will
be checkmate
but neither went for the absolute worst
move he played Queen captures on h7 and
this allowed a very nice idea he
completely missed from Breslau rubber so
feel free to pause the video here and
find the the move that allows the white
to seize advantage here so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those of you who just
maybe one enjoy show
he played Queen to a5 what does this do
well firstly it opens up an attack from
the rook to the Queen the Queen of
course has to move you can to block with
the night because both Queen and rook
are attacking the h5 square
so you
have to move the Queen but then the rook
controls the entire H file so the king
you know the H file is off-limits for
the King another thing this move does it
it threatens rook to d8 and now the
Queen is also guarding the d8 square so
how do you prevent this neither did play
the best move he played Queen to e4 and
now the move you have to find in order
to figure this out is not rook to d8 it
seems like this is the way to go but not
really because 98 simply stops it and
now you can't capture any material here
because you would get check mated with
the Queen captures on h1 so you'd have
to probably double up and then after g6
black will be completely fine and
probably win this game eventually the
move you had to find and the move
Brussels rubber found is actually rock
to h4 this is an excellent move and now
what do you do here well now there is no
Queen captures on h1 this is this is the
main part and another thing is the Queen
was forced to go to e4 and now rock to
h4 comes with tempo this is why all this
is so fascinating so here what Queen to
c6 Knight or could still have you know
continues to play this game but it's
very hard to realize that before you
actually see it the idea is now that if
the rook ever leaves the the first rank
then Roxy one will be checkmate after
Knight CalPERS and Queen captures but
here neither of missed this he played
Queen to b7 and now the game is over
immediately here
borislav rubber played rook to d8 check
we have nice the 8 of course only move
you don't want to capture and now Queen
to h5 and this is the move that he
missed it was in this position unmoved
32 that Miguel night off resigned in the
game so now you can see that the Queen
would would have been better off here
and c6 because now rook to see one would
be checkmate in two but here there's
really nothing you can do Queen to h8
checkmate is coming if you try to escape
you're not really gonna have a lot of
success in it you can either now try and
checkmate the black king or simply grab
more material and black is completely
busted
so after Queen to h5 a very nice victory
from Bratislava robber
and you know always always nice to see a
game in the night of variation of the
Sicilian and it's very interesting
neither most famous games in the night
of Sicilian are actually the ones that
he lost so yeah I did prepare the the
standings for this tournament so these
are the standings after this tournament
as you can see here we have Brussels
Gras bar somewhere after the middle and
Miguel night off in the middle so
neither of them have actually qualified
for the 1956 candidates tournament in in
Amsterdam the person who won this
tournament was David branch and of
course second was Paul Karras
but the Davin but David Ronson really
completely obliterated the field with 15
out of 20 that's 10 wins 0 losses and 10
rows so an amazing result in such a
strong field and it's interesting out of
the nine players who qualify for the
candidates tournament in Amsterdam in
1956 neither of them actually won the
candidates tournament it was the one
player who had a free ticket to the
candidates of course Vasily's missile
because he already faced Botvinnik in
the World Chess Championship match so it
was missile and the nine players from
this tournament and then smyslov
again crushed the field even with David
Bronson in such top form so very
interesting and also maybe not a bad
idea for a series and we do have a photo
challenge I decided to put the photo
challenge at the end of the video
because this photo challenge will also
announce the next video I will be making
as I couldn't find the photo between
Bratislava Robin and Miguel neither from
this tournament so instead I found
another one also a follow from the 1955
intra zonal tournament in Gothenburg
feel free to try and guess who the
players playing here are so it's it's
it's a one famous game between them and
it's a game I will I will show in my
next video it's quite outstanding and
you know you should definitely
definitely know this game so yeah best
of luck to everyone and yeah I do hope
you enjoyed this game it's quite quite
an amazing game and you know once again
thank you Jacob Roth for suggesting it
you know to honor Croatia on such
to victory against Argentina so yeah I
would like to thank Alexandra piece Dani
McCullough and Agatha matters dog for
contribution to my channel Thank You
Otto really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I think all for watching and
I will see you soon with that
interesting game we already mentioned so
thank you all and I'll see you soon